to us modern folk we tend to take for
granted the existence of cells and the
idea that all living things are made up
of cells that we as human beings as
living organisms were made up of many
many many cells and the the estimates of
the cells in the human body are on the
order of 37 37 trillion
trillion cells but if we were to rewind
even 400 years ago to the 1600s this
wasn't so obvious and that's because
people really didn't have the tools to
make direct observations of cells they
didn't know that these cells were around
they didn't know that things even like
unicellular organisms even existed but
all of that began to change with robert
hook
robert hook
was able to leverage primitive
microscope and this is a picture of his
microscope when you see this you
appreciate how at least relative to what
we have today how primitive it was he
had lenses here that would provide some
magnification but he had to use this
right over here this is a flame and
we're able he's able to channel that
light so that it gets reflected over
whatever he's observing and in 1665
he publishes the micrographia i'm
probably not producing it i'm probably
not pronouncing it right so this is 1665
robert hook publishes this and in this
he he describes and he draws a lot of
his observations using his microscope
and he has some fascinating drawings
he's actually quite a good artist where
he's able to draw pictures
of his observations of things like lice
and and fleas
but it's not just lice and fleas that
he's able to observe he actually takes a
look at some cork some corks or what
what he just sees as cork and when he
makes that observation he says hey look
you know there's these little there are
these little squares over here and this
kind of seems to be somehow kind of a
basic unit of of this of this cork and
he says well this kind of reminds me of
of these little these little rooms that
monks live in and spend their time in
which we call cells so he calls these
cells
and that's where the word comes from he
calls themselves in micrograffia
that is a cell now unfortunately for us
he was a great artist and and or he he
was really good at drawing things and he
drew a lot in his micrograffia but we
don't have any pictures of robert hook
anymore it's a fascinating story uh most
theories are that uh actually it was
isaac newton burned the only the only
original of painting that we have of
robert hook and that's another
intriguing story that we can talk about
at a future date
but what robert hook he coined these
things cells but he was looking at dead
tissue and actually he was looking at
the remnants of cells and what he saw
was really just the cell wall the cell
wall remnants he wasn't actually able to
observe directly living cells and he
didn't have enough to go on to think hey
maybe this is a building block of all
life and maybe cells themselves
reproduce and and all cells come from
other cells and that doesn't start to
get developed until we get further on
into history you go a few years later we
get to anthony von
luvenhook luvenhook i know i'm not
probably pronouncing it right but he was
a dutch lens crafter and he was inspired
by hook's work he says well hey i can
craft lenses maybe i can use that to
make better microscopes and make better
observations and he was able to do that
and doing that he was able to directly
observe living cells and living
unicellular organisms so he was able to
directly observe sperm he said wait this
thing this thing is looks like it's
alive he was able to observe
he was able to directly observe protists
so these unicellular eukaryotic they
have cell walls these things that look
like unicellular animals and he called
them actually
animal cules
and
molecules
saying hey look these look like these
like little these little mini animals
going on here and so he started saying
well maybe this is some form of a basis
of life or at least he's trying to say
that these at this very small scale you
actually have life
but a fully modern theory of the cell
doesn't really start to emerge until we
get another 100 150 years into the
future and we get into the early 1800s
so if you go if we fast forward to the
1830s these two gentlemen matthias
schleiden and theodore schwann come into
the picture and they're the ones that
start laying the foundation of what we
could call modern cell theory
so modern
modern cell theory and using their
observations and and kind of what they
were able to deduce they said hey
maybe maybe
maybe all living things
all life
is composed of one or more cells
is composed
of one or more cells
one or more cells and today we kind of
take this for granted but this wasn't
obvious it wasn't obvious at all things
that this is somehow a building block
for life one or more
one or more cells and then following
that if all life is composed of one or
more cells you could also say that a
cell is the basic unit of life
cell
is basic
basic
unit
of life and these are strong statements
that all life if you were to get down
small enough you're going to come you're
going to come to cells living cells that
make up that life
now this isn't our full complete cell
theory and both of these gentlemen they
knew that cells could come from other
cells they were able to observe cells
reproducing but they but it still was an
open question hey maybe some cells come
from other cells while others maybe they
sometimes somehow get spontaneously
created if you have the right elements
and the right amount of uh conditions
maybe they somehow just emerge out of
nothing and it wasn't until this kind of
third tenet of modern it wasn't until
the mid 1800s that we get our third
tenet of modern cell theory that gets
established and this is this idea that
all cells
all cells come from other cells all
cells from
from
other cells and the real father of this
idea the one that really established
this is this gentleman right here robert
rimac now sometimes the credit for this
goes to rudolph verchower vercau right
over here but it turns out that he
plagiarized re max work he plagiarized
re max work right over here so it's
really re mac who should
who deserves the bulk of the credit for
this tenant that all cells come from
other cells and once again he wasn't the
first person to say hey we'll observe
that some cells come from other cells
but say no this is a this is a
fundamental thing all cells this is how
they actually come about they aren't
just somehow
spontaneously emerged now whenever even
in today's world people see this lasting
all cells come from other cells there's
a natural question well there must have
been a a first cell or a initial set of
protocells
and people aren't 100 sure
but when we look back at at l the
evolution of life on earth we think the
first cells emerged about three and a
half billion years ago and we're not 100
sure about how they emerged but there
are some theories for example we have
videos on phospholipids and it turns out
that phospholipids naturally
naturally form
naturally form bilayers so phospholipids
naturally form bilayers
and they can actually form spherical
they can form spherical membranes that
have phospholipid bilayers so that kind
of gets you a start so that can
spontaneously form and there's also
theories that maybe the information the
machinery of cells
may be their their ancestry for three
and a half billion or longer ago that it
might have been maybe it was
self-replicating rna molecules or maybe
it was somehow self-replicating proteins
that over time over very large large
time scales were able to
start start replicating themselves have
more sophisticated machinery the the the
the ones that had kind of we're
approaching our modern cells we're able
to reproduce more we're able to take
advantage of kind of more of the energy
the resources in an environment so that
we eventually get with our modern cells
but this is a fascinating question and
still an area of research